le pont de la marsa 20 attrape avec la
gare de triage en toile de fond c'est le
lieu choisi par luc miserait pour
déclarer sa candidature aux élections
législatives dans la 11e circonscription
des yvelines
une campagne lancée sur la thématique
des transports par exemple de la gare de
triage de trappes qui est aujourd'hui en
jachère alors que là ce sont à la fois
des centaines d'emplois à la fois on a
d'un côté l'aspect marchandises un qui
est important et puis de l'autre côté on
à la gare de trappes mais il ya aussi le
prolongement de l'autoroute a12 que nous
on n'a pas enterré ainsi monsieur font
mouche à enterrer ben nous on l'a pas
enterrer ces problèmes là il faut s'y
atteler à la fois pour les problèmes
d'environnement et de santé publique
mais en même temps pour fluidifier la
circulation et l'irrigation de ces zones
industrielles et commerciales conseiller
municipal d'opposition à la mairie de
trappes luc mise rémission une campagne
de terrain en allant à la rencontre des
citoyens déjà ça fait longtemps qu'ils
travaillent sur le secteur sur trappe
l'oci dans le mouvement associatif et
c'est important d'avoir géré un candidat
je dirais qu'il est bien ancrée dans le
terrain connaît bien son secteur c'est
une candidature qui est portée largement
à gauche pour construire un
rassemblement le plus large possible des
forces qui se réclament
je dirais delà de la
la bataille contre les forces de
l'argent
prochain rendez vous sur des lieux
symboliques de la 11e circonscription
notamment au prisme à elancourt pour
évoquer les politiques culturelles